you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now well
John we're getting a little taste of
that storm finally as the southern end
of it swinging through Southern
California and entire area very low
clouds we've had some showers
temperatures have we're warming up a
little bit and then started to cool off
with some of the rain 48 at Mountain's
Edge 47 in Summerlin otherwise we've got
mid to low 50s around the valley and I
don't think we'll get a whole lot warmer
unless we get some breaks in those
clouds and I don't see too many at least
over the next few hours 55 in prom 50 in
Indian Springs we've had strong Gusty
southerly winds consistently in Indian
Springs up to Ely 37 there and we've
also had some pretty strong winds around
Kingman 40 plus mile an hour winds here
over the last couple of hours now 61 in
Kingman those southerly winds helping to
push the temperature and even up
Northwest of the Las Vegas Valley we've
had some winds clocked at 55 plus miles
an hour so the rain is starting to move
along I-15 and making its way into
Southern Nevada the bulk of this storm
is moving into Northern California in
the Pacific Northwest but there's enough
energy enough moisture to push right up
into Southern Nevada and it's staying on
track and just as we expected late
morning hours through the afternoon we
should see some somewhat persistent and
consistent showers through the rest of
the day snow also falling in our local
mountains winter storm warnings are in
effect there until 5 a.m tomorrow and we
do expect snow levels to stay somewhat
High six to seven thousand feet so not
down around Red Rock no photo
opportunities there unfortunately I know
a lot of people love to get out there
and take beautiful pictures when the
snow levels are lower Harris Springs
this is near what state route 157 up in
the mountains almost four tenths of an
inch of rain Lone Mountain and Hualapai
in the Northwest Valley almost a tenth
of an inch so far 215 in Revere in the
North End of the valley about 400th of
an inch same for near Henderson and
that's 2 15 and I 5 15. so this is the
second storm the first one was over New
Year's weekend there are several more
lined up out there and while we won't
get rain from all of them California
will get hit very consistently our next
chance for rain after today pretty much
comes on Monday into Tuesday so just
expect showers through the rest of the
afternoon wet streets for us highs that
will wind up in the mid 50s and the
mountain rain and snow so snow above
6000 feet and that's up around Kyle
Canyon I think we'll be getting snow but
and up to the ski resort but other than
that I think it's going to be rain so
slick roads 56 for the high rain likely
through the afternoon Ending by the
evening commute tomorrow mostly sunny
clouds back for the weekend ahead of our
next opportunity for rain John and that
slight chances for Monday with showers
likely again on Tuesday all right we
need the rain Cherry we do all right
next year on 8